okay so the topic of this video is going
to be chemical energy and a molecule
called adenosine triphosphate ATP you
know here's a structural drawing of an
ATP molecule and here's kind of a more
three-dimensional realistic diagram of
an ATP molecule so what we're gonna do
is we're going to learn about this
molecule called ATP let's get started
alright as we discussed chemical energy
and ATP our food that we eat will be you
what will supply the glucose and the
lipids that are required to build ATP
molecules so you know in the picture we
have a plate of pasta here you know
pastas high in carbohydrates and glucose
is a carbohydrate
well there's also lipids in the foods
that we eat and so glucose from our
foods and lipids from our foods are
gonna be used to build ATP molecules
adenosine triphosphate and so energy for
our cells to do work will be stored in
the bonds of an ATP molecule so here's a
molecule of ATP and particularly you can
see the three phosphates member it's
called triphosphate you can see the
three phosphates on the left of this
diagram that's typically where the
energy for cells to do work is going to
be stored in between those bonds holding
the phosphates together and so if we
look at this more simplistic diagram
right here we can see adenosine
triphosphate the blue peas there's three
phosphate three peas stuck together
and the my notes say that energy is
released when that third phosphate is
broken off and so that third the bond
that holds the second to the third
phosphate together the bond that holds
the second P to the third P that bond is
fairly unstable and it's easily broken
and watched this when that third
phosphate is broken energy is released
energy usually in the form of heat is
released and that heat will kind of
stimulate cells to to do various
functions and notice what's left over
you have two broken remains of ATP left
over and when you have the
a will you have the adenosine
diphosphate I hope you see why it's
called diphosphate dye is a prefix that
means two so the molecule on the left
that's left over
it's called adenosine diphosphate and
there's that broken off phosphate on the
right still okay so now that that third
phosphate has been broken off ATP can
actually be recreated
so notice you have adenosine diphosphate
ADP on the left and that broken
phosphate on the right well with the
addition of energy from the food that we
eat in various enzymes that broken
phosphate can be reattached to recreate
ATP this way our cell can have more ATP
for more energy so if we again take a
look at an ATP molecule here well when
that third phosphor phosphate is broken
off that's going to release energy for
ourselves to do work and then what
you're left over with are the broken
pieces you have the adp and that broken
phosphate well with energy from the food
that we eat that broken phosphate can be
reattached to adp to recreate a teepee
now this is actually called the ADP ATP
cycle this process continues over and
over from from birth until death okay so
check out my question on top how will a
DP bond to that one single P that one
single phosphate in the middle of the
picture we have an adenosine diphosphate
at the bottom right hand corner there is
that broken off phosphate how can we
attach the two I hope you recall from
earlier in the school year there's a
chemical reaction process where larger
molecules are built from smaller
molecules and that's called a
dehydration synthesis reaction so watch
this when those molecules come together
enzymes will help break some of those
bonds and water will be removed when
water is removed that broken off
phosphate connects to the ADP to make a
larger molecule called adenosine
triphosphate so if you recall from
earlier in this
your dehydration synthesis builds
molecules from smaller molecules so just
the opposite here's a larger ATP
molecule how would this larger ATP
molecule be broken down into smaller ADP
molecules well if you recall there's the
process called hydrolysis hydrolysis
means with hydro means implies water and
lysis lysis is a word that simply means
to break and so with water being added
and through the help of with the help of
various enzymes look at that hydrolysis
a hydrolysis reaction will occur that a
tipi molecule has been broken down into
adp that will release energy usually in
the form of heat and that energy in the
form of heat can be used to kind of
jumpstart various cellular activities
okay when we look at the process of
digestion
you know digestion the think about the
purpose of digestion and simply break
the food that we've eaten into usable
molecules once the food that we've eaten
has been broken down into usable
molecules those usable molecules will
hopefully help create ATP and so here's
a hamburger pretending to just eaten
this hamburger for lunch if we zoom into
the hamburger you know we can see that
you know there's complex sugars inside
of hamburgers and a complex sugar is
again made up from smaller simple sugars
a complex sugar you might remember is
actually called a polysaccharide and the
simple sugars if you recall are called
monosaccharides well through the
digestion that complex sugar will get
broken down into its simple sugar
components well let's just focus on one
simple sugar so if we just focus on one
simple sugar through the bra through the
breakdown of this one simple sugar for
instance glucose glucose is a simple
sugar through the breakdown of glucose
ATP is going to be created now higher
calorie foods will produce more ATP
molecules because higher calorie foods
have more of those glucoses in them and
so of course the more glucose
there is the more ATP will be created
now when we look at here's a diagram of
glucose you know one molecule of glucose
through a process that we're gonna learn
later on this chapter called cellular
respiration one glucose molecule will
actually be used to make up to 36 ATP
molecules and it's even more when you
look at a lipid here's a triglyceride a
lipid number triglycerides are three
fatty acids connected to a glycerol head
and so one triglyceride can actually
yield up to 146 ATP molecules so you see
we got a lot more ATP from fats now that
doesn't mean we go out and eat a lot a
lot a lot of fats to make more and more
and more ATP because there's always so
much ATP we can use in a day if our body
produces more ATP than can be used of
course the energy will be stored and
stored in the form of fat now what about
proteins you know proteins are common in
the foods that we eat but notice how how
you know the proteins are not usually
digested to build ATP when you look at a
protein here's a picture ever again of a
chain of amino acids which is what
proteins are made from when you look at
a picture like this when proteins are
broken down those amino acids are
usually going to be used for other
processes so those amino acids I have I
have to be used elsewhere so the ATP
typically comes from the carbohydrates
and gluten and glucose that we eat and
from the lipids that we eat so to kind
of wrap up this video here when we look
at the energy on earth it really starts
with the Sun so most life on earth
relies directly or indirectly on the Sun
I do say most because there is this
peculiar group of creatures in the
deepest bottomless parts of the ocean
we'll get to those in a moment but most
life relies either directly or
indirectly on the Sun you know I thought
these are just very pretty images right
here various images of our Sun
taken from NASA satellites different
light filters on them showing the
different kinds of energy that the Sun
can give off well when we look at
directly organisms that directly rely on
and the Sun for energy would be
autotrophs such as plants no plants are
not the only autotrophs but the most
common want and plants obtain energy
directly from the Sun by doing
photosynthesis so do some cyanobacteria
there's some photosynthetic bacteria so
do algae these are things that directly
get their energy from the Sun indirectly
let's not forget that you know consumers
heterotrophs such as this animal this
rabbit here you know rabbits are
herbivores and they eat plants and then
plants feed directly on sunlight so the
rabbit doesn't get energy directly from
the Sun the rabbit gets energy directly
from the plant the plant gets energy
directly from the Sun let's not forget
the meat-eaters out there such as the
wolf you know the Wolves get energy
indirectly from the Sun wolves get their
energy directly from rabbits or some
other small you know rodents perhaps a
mouse or something or a rat
so wolves will get their energy directly
from eating some kind of smaller animal
which that smaller animal before it was
caught by the wolf you know fed on a
plant which got its energy directly from
the Sun so like my notes say most life
relies on the Sun directly or indirectly
but the exceptions would be the chemo
troves you know here's a picture of an
underwater hydrothermal vent and you can
see there's some black smoke billowing
out of this hydrothermal vent a little
crack in the crust and so all this smoke
is coming out from the mantle of the
earth and there are organisms down there
called keema Tropes well first of all it
in that black smoke there are there's a
gas that called sulfides that are being
released in into the the ocean water
there are bacteria down there called
keema troves that will feed on those
sulfides so there's a unique group of
bacteria that will feed on
sulphides in order to make their ATP and
this is a process called chemosynthesis
and the bacteria that do chemosynthesis
are called kima troves but even though
this is a rare exception I do want to
stress the top of the notes most life on
Earth relies directly or indirectly on
the Sun to make their energy so there
you go
you can pause this video and you know
try to answer these questions if you're
in my biology class put your answers on
that separate sheet of paper I'd love to
check your answers before school or
after school for accuracy good luck